today's Wednesday August 20th and this
is gamespot news I'm Chris waters here
to catch you up on all the latest gaming
news in the least cool accent you will
ever hear on this show I think it's
important we all acknowledge our
shortcomings for example did you know
Jess MacDonald has webbed toes and Lucy
James as a werewolf those might not
actually be flaws
well now I'm depressed let's do the news
let's kick it off with some new game
announcements shall we from the makers
of Alien Hominid Castle Crashers and
battleblock theater comes space bear
death Cataclysm featuring star okay
that's not what it's called the teaser
released by developer the behemoth
refers to their new project as simply
game 4 and according to a press release
it will be in a quote genre they haven't
covered before and seek to breathe a new
flavor into FPS RTS MMORPG MOBA other
game abbreviation speculate wildly in
the comments below and mark your
calendars for the last week in August
when we're gonna have the behemoth and
game 4 live on our stage show at PAX
Prime it's not an announcement per se
but there may be a new Resident Evil
game in the making and no I did not mean
remaking polygon has reported that a
listing for Resident Evil Revelations 2
appeared briefly on Xbox comm before
being removed indicating that a sequel
may be in the works
revelations first appeared on the 3ds
and HD versions later came to the Xbox
360 Playstation 3 Wii U and PC it was
well received by critics and sold over a
million copies all told so it's a solid
sequel candidate but despite the
revelations to listing and rumors that
they're working on Resident Evil 7
Capcom's only announced re-project is an
HD version of the very first Resident
Evil Call of Duty advanced warfare is
not coming to the Wii U that's pretty
much the whole story Activision has
sledgehammer games working on the Xbox
one ps4 and PC versions high Moon
Studios working on the Xbox 360 and ps3
versions and nobody working on the Wii U
versions because it doesn't exist
q sad trombone music
and let's keep that sound effect handy
because alas dear miners sweet crafters
minecraft for the ps4 has failed final
testing with Sony developer 4j Studios
tweeted the news earlier today saying
Sony has found some issues we have to
fix in their final test of hashtag
minecraft ps4 brownie face we're fixing
but we need to go through the process
again originally scheduled to release
this month minecraft on the ps4 will
likely be delayed as a result of the
testing failure leaving minecraft
players with only a million different
platforms on which to mine craft and
design functioning hard drives that'll
about do it for today's show if you're
hungry for more news there are two
stories up on the site about the new
Assassin's Creed games rogue and unity
you can find them at gamestop comm slash
news now if you'll excuse me time for
lunch calm / sandwich from home HTML
question mark plaintiff at my desk
equals one see you tomorrow